je fais la promesse d mais finalement et
de te protéger
à lever les yeux au ciel je rêve pas tu
envisages des représailles je passe te
prendra cinq heures sauf si je n'ai pas
terminé d'ici là
alors pourquoi tu désolé madame grès
c'est pour te protéger
alors quelle nouvelle anna nous sommes
suivis
[Musique]
bonjour la fin bonjour mon mari madame
grès regarder par la fenêtre
je vous emmène en week-end j'ai du mal à
croire que c'est ma vie que j'ai la
chance de vivre avec toi
douze mois
euroda n'agrège écoute
je passe te prendra cinq heures sauf si
je n'ai pas terminé d'ici là oui je peux
conduire non elle est magnifique je vais
acheter pour nos jeunes a tort christian
tu
elle est idéalement situé je vais vous
construire une maison de rêve
arrêtez de parler à mon mari comme si je
n'étais pas là anna vous pouvez
m'appeler madame grès
je devrai désobéir plus souvent
nous sommes suivis
[Musique]
alors quelle nouvelle anna jack vous
voulez quoi
[Musique]
tu as envie de jouer oui monsieur
question
j'ai juré de te protéger je le ferais tu
ne peux pas m'enfermer dans une cage
j'ai fait la promesse de thé mais
finalement
en renonçant à toute autre tu as couché
avec
et de te réconforter dans la détresse
aussi longtemps que nous vivons pourquoi
est ce que tu me défi
parce que je t'aime tu es beau